[Music]
one simple way that's not a simple
question get rid of all your stuff give
it away treat everybody the way that you
want to be treated
Wow keep the minimum gave a lot of stuff
away just to forgive seriously forgive
stop worrying so much about things that
you can't change and if you can't change
it will do have trust that everything
will work out stop worrying about the
people that bring you down
big lots of notes tell the truth to say
no drink a lot of coffee it's my go-to
for everything get a dog
don't multitask do one thing at a time
give it your full attention
mindfulness don't do Facebook don't do
anything where people are telling you
what to look at no social media turn off
your electronic devices one day a week
stop worrying
just take it slow spend time with a
friend
[Music]
I think like is just as complicated as
you making you overthink something that
could be complicating so it's all based
on what you do find something that makes
you happy like maybe go out in work or
early help other people or whatever
makes you happy laughs more do yoga to
trust yourself more than anything come
up with a priority for one thing you
want to accomplish in a day and just
focus on that until you accomplish it
if everyone would love you
the right way and
you have to communicate with everybody
around you
in any situation remember to breathe
[Music]
eat ice cream
I would say just choose to be happy I
think your attitude is really 99% of
what makes you a happy person and if you
walk around every day and choose to have
a good attitude that I think life can be
a lot less complicated you just have to
let go I'm just following your bliss I
guess
to stop overthinking because once you
saw that doubt it'll make everything a
lot more simple everyone getting along
how's that how do you do that try to
understand each other what's your name
my name is Robert and
so the question for today is what's one
simple way to make life less complicated
one simple way is to choose to live a
relaxed life perfect thank you
[Music]
you